so boobage's job go right after these
guys you know mix them up but not
overpower
like he's been doing he's been doing a
nice job he's got a great era 1.52 first
batter he will face is kyle garlick
oh baby
in there a strikeout on the four scene
fastball at 92 miles an hour
donaldson with one down in the first
inning
donaldson drives it hard to left field
ben and tendy back and it's gone into
the bullpen josh donaldson cranks one
out
his sixth home run of the year
and the twins take a one-nothing lead
that was just what he and the twins
needed going up there being aggressive
got a pitch
and a hitter's count right in the middle
of the plate and he did not miss it and
good for the twins to play with the lead
helps everyone settle in a little bit
just a simple little
four scene fastball tried to get it in
donaldson you see a head perfect
position on this swing seeing that
contact and then watching that ball jump
out of the ballpark
for the twins with the man on with two
out a run in and now trevor larnick
comes to the plate
which strikes him out though he gets a
couple of strikeouts in the inning but
gives up a home run to donaldson with
the jay happ
also made his last start against these
royals good job his last start game got
the win in that ball game and gave his
team a chance to win well salvi had
quite a game on tuesday
and he busts this one to center field
coming back
that ball is a gun wow
salvador perez on the very first pitch
hit one about 450 feet and ties the game
the iron man lou gehrig would be proud
of that shot from salvador perez going
way deep here at coppin stadium that
ball got small in a hurry look at that's
a pitch way outside up and away and he
was able to reach out there with his
long arms and barreled it
that was a no doubter to that part of
the ballpark you don't see a lot of no
doubters there that was his sixth first
pitch home run this year well you know
what andrew benintendi did on tuesday
with the bases loaded just get a run
home really that's all they want to do
here
oh and he hits him in the back and gets
a run home
that'll work
now solaire in 175 on the year but 243
with
men in scoring position
and now big tall pop-up
donaldson
with the catch
royals get one leave three it's two to
one kansas city
karnik will lead things off in cino and
jeffers
and a swing and a miss
boobic now with five strikeouts and
here's the kid
celestino well he decides to
and celestino had no chance and strikes
out that's six for chris tonight gordon
trying to get a hit here
and a base hit to right
gordon delivers a two-out hit so no
scores and the game is tied
bottom of the fourth hunter dozier leads
off against jay happ
and the lefties pitch is swung on and
hit well to left field carrying toward
the bullpen it is gone
looks like a first pitch breaking ball
and
leonardo
who
over his career has had a great deal of
success on the first pitch just hit a
line drive over the wall on left field
and the royals have regained the lead
3-2
here is a good contact guy in merrifield
went to left field and deep
it'll be deep enough to score the run
alberto tags and comes home and the
royals take a 4-2 lead
the 11th double for donaldson here's
polanco to bat
and he'll swing away and drive in a run
with a base head donaldson around third
polanco going to second and he is in
goes in standing up
looking to get something elevated
and sono lifts it high to center field
deep enough to score polanco and there's
your productive out with polanco scoring
the tying run
salvador perez
and he'll stand in the lead off the
fifth and he'll
hit a high drive down the right field
line right fielder to the fence looking
up and it's gone
salvi goes oppo and the royals retake
the lead 5-4
salvador perez a two-home run game
that's his 14th of the year
and he is on a tear
savvy just hit two home runs
in the royals last game tuesday night
and so this is his eighth career
multi-home run game
as he goes to the opposite field
josh donaldson leading
the seventh inning off for the twins
with the twins down to run donaldson's
got a home run
and a double two run scored
melts into center and deep and donaldson
has tied the game with another home run
a home run to left a double to right and
now a home run to center and we are tied
at five nice job with the twins coming
back and answering more than once in
this ball game but you look at his head
right down on this ball seeing the
contact
finishing falling through getting
extended and driving this ball out of
the big part of the ballpark and real
good sign for the twins if he can start
heating up
dyson goes pitch taken throw is not in
time
boy he was going into second so fast he
almost slid past it well you know when
your helmet flies off and almost goes
into the left field you know there's a
lot of momentum going there for sure
dyson with a good hard slide and it
looked to me
like gordon had his foot right in front
of the base so when you go head first
look at his foot gordon you got to miss
that foot gordon's going to put his foot
right in front dyson finds the corner
there and is able to hold himself on the
bite look at the helmet flying out the
left field so now let's see if ben and
tindy can get dyson home and break that
5-5 tie
flying ball left center
oh and it's dropped
and dyson goes to third
a big mistake by minnesota and here
comes dyson to score and the royals will
take the lead
celestino the rookie center fielder for
the minnesota twins
you know the outfield they're not used
to playing together it's larnick
and celestino and you know when you're
not used to playing with each other they
didn't have spring training or anything
with all their injuries out there
you know that that's unfortunate
for rocco ball daily in the minnesota
twins and then that throw right there so
that's two errors on one play and the
royals are taken
that's what you call an outfield gap
and both on the kid
celestino
now donaldson
he is a lane ball candidate and what i
mean by that
put him in the lane the double play lane
he's grounded into nine this season so
far
up the middle merrifield touches second
first right you are hud a double play to
end it
ten
ground ball double plays to win he'll
take it barlow nice job
knew it all along how about that what a
game tonight